there is no single Source there's no
doctrinal Source because a lot of
individuals who've written their books
and shared their ideas as red pill and
depending on where what school of
thought you're in a lot of individuals
will say well that's not red pill for me
he's not red pill for me maybe in your
world he's red pill for you and some
people red pill for them might be coach
Greg Adams be a red pill for them might
be fresh and fit you could wear a pill
for that might be AMS to be red pill for
that might be coach red pill from people
right people for them they all seem to
say the same idea well yes yes it's like
so I'm just like if we're if we're gonna
say they're different like what what is
different okay so in regards to each
individual I can't get into nuances of
each individual so there are some
individuals who are when it comes to
marriage are explicitly marriage I think
the whole institution of marriage in the
western world is done it's over it
doesn't work it's a failed system XY I
agree XYZ cool so so that's why that's
why red pill aligns to you because those
emotional sentiments a rock with you so
then there's other emotional it's
because of the legal the way it is
legally a hundred percent so those those
legal sentiments yeah rock with you and
we can get into it okay how does those
things fleshed out but then on the flip
side which you have other individuals
who say well in actuality well I I do
believe that in the sanity and beauty of
marriage and if you're gonna do marriage
outside of the state I'm all for it
right so yeah some people is like even
with or without the state institution is
broken women are broken Society is
broken doesn't even matter and some
people are like well well outside of the
state yeah I supported I agree with you
it seems like their prescriptions are
are different but their description is
the same yeah typically so like they'll
say these are the flaws in women these
are the flaws in in marriage but like
they have different prescriptions so
some people will still go through with
it with a prenup and other people will
say screw it all together and so so
prescribing a behavior yeah is telling
people what to do and telling people
what to do also creates a form of an
ideology so if I say I have 10 rules
that I believe mentioned to follow and
then say I have no ideology that doesn't
make any sense so to me an ideology
isn't a bad thing I have an ideology you
have an ideology every human has an
ideology so my biggest argument is not
that the ideology is bad but don't lie
and say that you don't have ideology
when we all have an ideology so and so
in regards to your original question
about the red pill I believe a lot of
the a lot of what they say is half
truths and like I said for example if
you really analyze human and a male
nature and female nature there's a lot
of really dark and disturbing things
about female nature when you when you
can get to the rawness of it right yeah
yeah and if you're an individual and
you're and you're simply communicating
those raw dark truths about what it was
true it could be very simple simple to
realize that wow man these are really
really bad things I'll give you an
example felons have 30 more children
than non-felons I love it yeah so I
don't I don't so you just threw out a
number yeah I've never heard that you
yeah you have nothing to back it up so
another example is I'm sorry we got we
got to stop there what happens in this
community what happens with with the
people who have the school of thought
they'll throw out numbers
where did that where did that stat come
from where did it come from where did it
come from off the top of my head I don't
know but it's easy to Google like if you
Google it it's like at the top it's easy
to Google right but the reality of the
matter is when people are sharing their
statistics and numbers a lot of times
they don't know they can't even tell you
the primary source so right because it's
like off the top of your head you're not
gonna know like 100 right there why
should I believe you why should I
believe you yeah okay but if I'm saying
if I got you the stat I could look it up
now I know you could look you could take
your time you could pause everything you
can look it up but my point is that a
lot of times in this community they'll
throw statistics and data at you you not
you don't have you're not privy to
assisting data yeah some of it is true
some of it is false right I can go into
some of the truths and false as well and
so because you're not able to Simply
look things up you're in a conversation
where you're like okay I'm gonna give
this person the benefit of Doubt but but
if the data is simply skewed by sheer
numbers it can totally
um this um this spell whether this
person's communicating the truth or not
yeah but it's easy to just like Google
it I know but when I I'm saying is
listen carefully if you and I are having
a podcast conversation and you have 15
data points that justify your worldview
but you don't know the source you know
the primary secondary source we could
stop this episode and every time you
pull up numbers I could we could look at
you can look them up you can pull them
up you can show it to me but that's
going to take too long so usually
accomplish like this they don't you're
not able to do so so therefore what
you're forced to do in these
conversations is whenever someone gives
you a statistic the individual is called
to believe it and I've seen that happen
myself because I'm a data person as well
you've consumed my content so you know
some of it I'm a dated person myself so
when I share data there's times where I
was like oh well that number was wrong
but because we're in the middle of a
conversation people simply believe me
yeah and so to me one which is fine then
you just update it I know but but in the
midst of the conversation when we're
having these conversations and when
we're sharing all these data a lot of
people will spew data and numbers
it can be true really false I understand
sometimes misinformation happens 100 and
it's not perfect I'm not saying you're
trying to deceive me yeah but what I'm
saying is that there has to be a level
of accountability when we're saying this
is the truth so for one of the things
that I've been improving on in regards
to my speeches that if I share a number
if I really don't know the primary
source or I'm not willing to pull it up
immediately right I'll say well you know
I think this is the number or I'm not
sure this is another but what happens is
when you say 110 this is true the
divorce rate in America is 50 it's true
and then you share these explicit
narratives okay and then when you simply
analyze them and break them down you
realize that's not the case yeah but
then then you switch it but I don't
think it's wrong to just say a number
there's nothing wrong and then and then
and then and then I look it up and it's
right like I've looked that up before
that's not what I I think you're getting
lost you're getting lost in the specific
point I'm talking about the meta Point
The Meta point is that when people are
communicating statistics the audience
has I it's totally dependent upon their
orator and and if that person says I am
the bearer of the truth a lot of times
in the midst of a conversation a lot of
people communicate numbers that may or
may not be true so my biggest thing is
that when a lot of these individuals are
communicating numbers I'm the kind of
person where I'm like hey let's stop
let's analyze them and let's see whether
they're true or not is there a common
talking point that isn't true that
you're thinking of I think one of the
biggest conversations that is not
discussed is how marriage is has changed
from the 90s till today okay if you if
you if you look up the marriage the
divorce rates divorce rates have been
decreasing from the 1990s until today a
lot of different studies and a lot of
different analyzation
a lot of different so are you listening
are you trying to talk uh-huh unless I'm
curious I'm listening because you kind
of seem like you just you're waiting for
me to stop talking so you can say
something no I'm listening God are you
sure yeah I'm listening go ahead okay
so in regards to the divorce numbers a
lot of the divorce numbers that are
communicated today they they're not all
those are a lot of all previous numbers
and when you're factoring to the trends
that are leading to the lowering a
divorce rates as well as all the
different cross-cultural analysis of
divorces it's a lot that can be learned
about divorces so in regards to the
Western World a lot of the divorce is
having issues they're 100 right but we
have to communicate well here's the
reality the divorce rate has been going
down and why has divorce rate been going
down and the reason why the divorce
rate's going down is because we've
learned a lot of different things about
marriage about divorce about why the
divorce rate Skyrocket initially in
1970s begin with and so there's a lot of
when you hear a number statistics are
great under the broad scope of a
conversation but when you're really
trying to dive deeper into what's going
on to the society statistics tell you a
story right so once you understand the
story behind the number then you can
understand why the number is practical
so in my question is so when so one of
the biggest things that we've worked on
is that if we're going to give a number
we want to also tell the story behind a
number and how is that beneficial to
improving the lives of people today and
so to me that's one of my different
different points of view is that if
you're simply holding on to any world
view and the World Views communicating
certain things that may or not be true
or may not be painting the whole picture
is this for the purpose of benefiting
Society or is it for the purpose of
perpetuating a narrative as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible